This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。嘿，你们好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难抉择》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在其他地方根本不敢进行的坦诚对话，而在这里，你是在和一个懂行的执业专业人士进行交流。有多少男人带着一身铠甲。这向世界发出了信号：你不是好惹的。这并不意味着你有能力就必须去硬抗，
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,
在iHeart电台应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难抉择》。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会在另一面成为一个更快乐、
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
更有成就感、更健康的人。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应得的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
在iHeart电台应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《相信我，宝贝》（Trust Me, Babe）。在《回看往昔》（Look Back at It）播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和我来说是一个重要时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是山姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何度过那段时光的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show.
我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的嘉宾以及最喜欢的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回看往昔》。大家好。欢迎回到节目。
Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of your 20s. Before we get into this endlessly fascinating episode, I wanted to briefly talk. about something exciting and that is that my book is coming out on the 29th of April as I am recording this that is 21 days away which is insane to say out loud three weeks that is that's just amazing to me that in three weeks I will be a published author but if you didn't already know I have written a book called person in progress a roadmap to the psychology of
欢迎回到本播客。新听众、老听众，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。非常高兴你能来到这里收听又一期节目，当然，我们要剖析你20多岁时的心理。在我们进入这个无尽迷人的话题之前，我想简要聊聊。一件令人兴奋的事，那就是我的书将于4月29日出版。当我录制这段音频时，距离那天还有21天，说出来真让人难以置信，三周时间，对我来说简直太不可思议了，三周后我将成为一名出版作家。如果你还不知道的话，我写了一本名为《成长中的人：你20多岁心理指南》（Person in Progress: A Roadmap to the Psychology of）的书。
your 20s and it is exactly what the title says. It is an intricate psychological deep dive into everything that you would ever want to know about this decade. How to find your calling, how to find love, why it's so hard to find love, friendship breakups, taking risks, healing your inner child, authenticity, like I could go on and on and on, but one day, hopefully very soon, you'll have the opportunity to read it yourself. And it is my, humble request today that if you enjoy this podcast, if you have gotten something out of it, that you pre-order my book. Not only will you be getting more of the content that you hopefully love, but it really does support me. And, you know, book writing is not a money-making game.
你20多岁的心理，这完全符合书名所表达的意思。这是一次复杂的心理深潜，探索你关于这个十年可能想要了解的一切。如何找到你的天命，如何找到爱，为什么找爱这么难，友谊的破裂，承担风险，疗愈内在小孩，真实自我，我可以一直说下去，但希望在不久的将来，你会有机会亲自阅读它。今天我有一个小小的请求，如果你喜欢这个播客，如果你从中获得了收获，请预购我的书。你不仅能读到更多你希望喜欢的内容，这也确实是对我的支持。而且，你知道，写书并不是一门赚钱的生意。
Like, you don't really expect to make anything from writing a book. It's all just a bonus. So it's not about the money, I would just be so very grateful if you could support my work, share it with a friend, hopefully pre-order, but even just read the blurb online. Like any small act, any small support of this insane endeavor would be incredible. And I want to thank you in advance for showing up for the book, for hopefully reading it, hopefully gifting it. And I also want to express like some desperate extreme gratitude for giving me this opportunity. There is no if so buts about it. I would not have written a book if it was not for the psychology of your 20s listeners.
就像，你并不会真的指望靠写书发财。这全都是额外的收获。所以这无关金钱，如果你能支持我的工作，把它分享给朋友，希望能预购，甚至只是在网上读一下内容简介，我都会非常感激。任何微小的行动，对这项疯狂事业的任何一点支持，都将是不可思议的。我要提前感谢大家对这本书的支持，希望你们能阅读它，希望能把它当作礼物送人。同时，我也想表达我极端、迫切的感激之情，感谢你们给了我这个机会。毫无疑问。如果没有《20多岁心理学》的听众们，我是不会写这本书的。
And that is so apparent to me every single day. So I just want to say I am so grateful and I'm so excited to hear your thoughts about it, to see what you think and to, yeah, hopefully be able to provide you with even more of a roadmap to this confusing time. Okay, with all that in mind, without further ado, what are we talking about today? Because we're not talking about my book. We're talking about something very, very different. We're talking about the psychology of pre-menstrual syndrome, PMS. We are talking about this black box of hormones and mood swings and rage and acne and so many other things that impact a whole lot of people, but which I don't think I even really understood until
这一点我每天都深有体会。所以我只想说，我非常感激，也很高兴听到你们对它的想法，看看你们的看法，并且，是的，希望能为你们提供更多的指南，来应对这个令人困惑的时期。好了，考虑到所有这些，闲话少说，我们今天要聊什么呢？因为我们不打算聊我的书。我们要聊一个非常、非常不同的事情。我们要聊的是经前期综合征（PMS）的心理学。我们要聊聊这个充满了荷尔蒙、情绪波动、暴怒、长痘以及许多其他影响着巨多人的“黑匣子”，但在大约一年前，我觉得自己甚至并没有真正理解它。
a year ago. You know, I've had my period since I was 13, but something that I've noticed is that we actually know very little about our bodies on an individual scale. There are very few guides or times when somebody is going to sit down with you and just say, this is what's happening at your body at certain times of the month. This is why you feel this way. This is what your hormones do. This is how they influence mood. This is what you're is actually happening in this vessel that you have. You know, we're just expected to deal with it, even when it impacts our well-being, without ever actually having the information, that could actually make it better.
你知道，我从13岁起就来了月经，但我注意到的一件事是，实际上我们对自己的身体知之甚少，尤其是在个体层面上。很少有指南或这样的时刻：有人会坐下来对你说，这就是你的身体在每月的特定时间发生的事情。这就是你为什么会有这种感觉。这就是你的荷尔蒙的作用。这就是它们如何影响情绪。这就是在你拥有的这个躯壳里实际发生的事情。你知道，我们只是被期望去应对它，即使它影响了我们的健康，却从未真正获得能够让情况变得更好的信息。
But today I want to hopefully provide that guide to you around PMS and PMDD so that you can know yourself and know your body better and know how it interacts with your psychology because learning this in your 20s, you know, it's such an important time for you to start taking these kinds of things seriously and to start really feeling in touch with your body. And it's a great time to be reintroduced to so many ideas and concepts that we haven't even really spoken about since puberty, but a constant reality for us. So, yes, we're talking PMS, we're talking PMDD and we're talking periods, specifically the psychology behind why that period of time before our period takes such a toll and what's creating
但今天，我希望为大家提供一份关于PMS和PMDD（经前期恶劣情绪障碍）的指南，这样你就可以更好地了解自己、了解你的身体，以及它如何与你的心理相互作用，因为在20多岁时了解这一点，你知道，这是你开始认真对待这些事情、开始真正感知自己身体的重要时期。这是一个极好的时机，让我们重新认识许多自青春期以来就再也没有真正讨论过，但却一直伴随着我们的现实的想法和概念。所以，是的，我们要聊PMS，我们要聊PMDD，我们还要聊月经，特别是经期前的那段时间为什么会带来如此沉重的负担，背后是什么在起作用，以及如何应对这些情绪波动、挫折感，甚至可能伴随的羞耻感、心理影响、污名化，还有一些更小众的问题，比如：你是否应该在黄体期和伴侣分手？可能不应该。PMS是谋杀的好辩护理由吗？同样，不。我们有这么多小众的话题要聊。希望我已经。吸引了你，但我现在要停止闲聊，直接进入PMS的科学与心理学。请继续收听。好了，所以我们的身体、荷尔蒙和月经是如此复杂，而且对每个人来说都大不相同。你知道，我从未遇到过两个对子宫有完全相同体验的人。所以如果你经历PMS，它也会有所不同。但考虑到这一点，
that, but also how to manage those fluctuations, the frustration, maybe even the shame we feel, the mental impact, the stigma, and also some more niche questions like should you break up with your partner during your luteal phase? Probably not. Is PMS a good defense for murder? Also, no, we've got like so many niche things to talk about. Hopefully I have. you hooked, but I am going to stop rambling now and just get into the science and the psychology of PMS. Stay with us. Okay, so our bodies and hormones and periods are so complex and seriously different for everyone. You know, I've never met two individuals who have the same experiences with their uteruses. So if you experience PMS, it's going to be different as well. But with that in
在做出这个前提之后，让我们从一些关于PMS的非常基础的事实信息开始。现在，我们不会过多涉足医学领域，因为那不是我的专业领域，但对PMS的基本解释是这样的。PMS基本上描述了月经前出现的一系列症状或变化。据估计，大约四分之三来月经的人都会经历至少一个属于PMS范畴的变化，即使这些变化对我们来说并不明显。让我们来盘点一下其中一些变化，因为它们既有情绪上的，也有生理和心理上的。
mind, with that caveat being said, let's just start with some really basic factual information about PMS. Now, we're not going to go too much into the medical side of things because that's not my area of expertise, but the basic explanation of PMS is this. PMS basically describes a set of symptoms or changes that occur before your period. And it's estimated that about three quarters of people who get their period, experience at least one change that would fall under the umbrella of PMS, even if it's not noticeable to us. So let's go through some of these changes because they are both emotional and physical and psychological.
我先从那些我可以说似乎最常见的症状开始。最常见的有紧张和焦虑、抑郁情绪、爱哭、腹胀、长痘，还有情绪波动、易怒、食欲和食欲改变、失眠、疲劳、头痛、注意力不集中、性欲改变、社交退缩，等等。你知道，有些人甚至形容在黄体期也就是月经前夕想要和伴侣分手，他们把这归咎于自己的PMS。事实上，来月经的人在月经来潮前对自己的关系产生更多担忧是很常见的，因为他们对人际关系的敏感度或觉察力会高得多。
I'm going to start with the ones that I would say are seemingly most common. The most common ones are tension and anxiety, a depressed mood, crying spells, bloating, acne, but then also mood swings, irritability, appetite and craving changes, insomnia, fatigue, headaches, poor concentration, change in libido, social withdrawal, just to name a few. You know, some people even describe wanting to break up with their partner during their luteal phase right before their period and they kind of attribute it to their PMS. In fact, it's actually common for people who get their periods to have more concerns about their relationship right before they menstruate because they can be a lot more sensitive or aware of interpersonal problems.
我认为总体上会更加暴躁，我们会解释为什么会这样，因为这当然不仅仅是因为女人情绪化，这是一个真实的荷尔蒙问题。加州大学洛杉矶分校（UCLA）最近进行的一项研究确实发现，女性在经期周期的不同时间对伴侣的评价是不同的。有时，甚至在月经前夕会觉得伴侣没那么有吸引力。但这并不一定意味着她们想分手或对关系的承诺减少了。事情要复杂得多，它会产生很多微妙的复杂情感。如果你是一个有很多关系焦虑的人，有时在月经前夕的那段时间，
I think more irritable in general and we'll explain why that is because it's certainly not just because women are too emotional, it's a real hormonal thing, but a recent study conducted at UCLA did find that women evaluate their relationships differently at different times in their cycle. Sometimes, even finding their partners less attractive right before their period. But that doesn't necessarily mean they want to break up with them or are less committed. It's just a lot more complicated than that, and it can just create a lot of nuanced feelings. And if you're someone who has a lot of relationship anxiety, sometimes that time right before your period,
意识到自己将经历高度的敏感和怀疑，这一点真的非常重要。面对这种情况，你该如何保持中立，并认识到还有另一个因素在起作用？我们一会儿就会讨论这个问题。另一个我确信我们很多人都很熟悉有趣症状是身体形象的改变——在月经前，许多女性对身体的看法会发生重大变化。事实上，这可能并不让人意外。我们的身体形象和对身体的评估通常会变差。研究早在80年代和90年代就表明了这一点，这不仅仅是因为
it's really important to be aware of the fact that you are going to experience heightened sensitivity and doubts. And how can you stay neutral in the face of that, knowing that there's another factor contributing? We're going to talk about that in a second. But another interesting symptom that I'm sure a lot of us are familiar with is changes in body image, our views towards our bodies change significantly for many women before the period. In fact, this probably won't come as a surprise. Our body image and our appraisal of our body typically gets worse. Now, studies have shown this as early as the 80s and 90s, and it's not just because
我们腹胀了，这显然是一个因素。这是因为身体形象是我们自我概念的一部分。而我们的自我概念是由大脑、在某种程度上由我们的神经系统以及我们的感受所调节的。因此，当我们的神经系统因荷尔蒙变化而失调时，我们对自己的看法也会随之改变。对我来说，我总是经历这种情况。我总是觉得，真的没有比“恶心”更好的词来形容了。就像我觉得自己很恶心、很丑，就像个怪物一样，就在月经来临前，每次都是这样，准时在三天前，我会想：“哇，我从来没觉得自己这么肿过，我从来没
we're bloated, obviously that's a factor. It's because body image is a part of our self-concept. And our self-concept is regulated by our brain and to an extent our nervous system and how we're feeling. So when our nervous system is dysregulated because of hormonal changes, our opinion of our self will also change. For me, I always experience this. I always feel, you know, there's really no better word than like disgusting. Like I feel disgusting and ugly and like a monster right before my period and everything time like on the dot three days before i'll be like wow i have never felt more swollen and i've never
觉得自己这么丑过，我只觉得恶心，觉得自己会永远这样下去。”然后就是——“哦，砰！”我来月经了，一切都有了解释。而且我依然，我依然有这种无法将二者联系起来的问题——真的，我对身体缺乏自信往往只发生在经期前后，而且几乎每个月都会来一次，然而当这种糟糕的感觉突然袭来时，我还是会感到惊讶。我不知道你能不能感同身受，但我确实觉得，我们中的许多人对于身体和大脑会对每个月都要经历的一整个生命周期做出反应这件事，依然感到震惊。说真的，这就是事实。当你来月经时，你正处于那个生命周期的终点。是一样的。
felt uglier and i just feel disgusting and like i'm going to feel like this way forever and then it's like oh bam i get my period and it explains it all and i still i still have this issue of not being able to put two and two together like really my body my lack of body confidence only really comes around the time I get my period and it comes almost every single month and yet I'm still surprised when suddenly I feel awful. I don't know if you can relate but I do feel like for many of us we are still shocked by the fact that our bodies and our minds are going to react to the fact that we go through an entire life cycle every month. And seriously, that is what it is. When you get your period, you are at the end of that life cycle. That's the same.
这就是你整个生殖系统的运作方式。这就是为什么当你即将迎来月经时，它确实感觉像是一种死亡。就像你快要死了一样。你知道我的意思吗？然后一旦排卵期再次到来，你知道，你几乎会兴奋得嗡嗡作响，因为那是你卵子生命的黄金时期，你知道吗？这一切都是一个关于重生、更新、死亡和生命的循环。希望这个解释对你来说合情合理，
That's how your entire reproductive system is operating. That is why when you were about to get your period, it does feel like a kind of death. Like it feels like you're dying. Do you know what I mean? And then once ovulation comes back around, you know, you're practically buzzing because that's like the prime days of your egg's life, you know? And it's all a cycle of rebirth and renewal and death and life. And hopefully this explanation makes sense to you.
但它确实展示了为什么PMS会如此令人虚弱又沮丧。有时感觉你的身体真的在惩罚你。就像是，“好吧，你没有怀孕。给你，这就是你没做我们认为你该做的事的惩罚。”但再次强调，这一切都是发生在我们体内的那个非常重要的生辰与死亡循环的一部分，当你仔细想想，我觉得这相当壮观。我认为这绝对不可思议，这竟然是会发生的事情。所以还有一点需要注意，趣事——也许不是那么有趣，但随着年龄的增长，PMS症状实际上会变得更糟糕。
but it does just show why PMS can be so debilitating but also frustrating. Sometimes it feels like your body is almost punishing you in a real way. Like, okay, well, you didn't get pregnant. Here, this can be your punishment for not doing what we think you should be doing. But again, it's all part of that very important cycle of birth and death that are occurring in our bodies, which I think is quite spectacular when you think about it. I think that's just incredible that that is something that occurs. So something else to note, fun fact, maybe not so fun, but PMS symptoms will actually get worse the older we get.
而且离绝经和围绝经期越近就越严重。但一旦我们跨入绝经期，它就会停止。不过，在临近绝经的那个阶段，症状会达到最强烈，这合情合理，因为随着年龄增长，我们的荷尔蒙会发生变化，并且由于卵巢功能减退，波动会更加剧烈。但许多人谈到过这一点，她们谈到随着年龄的增长，她们越发觉得对这些荷尔蒙变化异常敏感。也许你也能感同身受。
And the closer we get to menopause and perimenopause. But once we pass over into menopause, it will stop. That approach though is when it's going to be at its most intense and that makes sense because our hormones, they change the older we get and they fluctuate more rapidly. The closer we get to menopause due to this decline in ovarian function. but a lot of individuals have spoken about this, have spoken about how the older they got, the more they felt that they were sensitive to these hormonal changes. Maybe that's something you can relate to.
你知道，在你来月经的前十年里，你从未注意到它。而现在，这个过程中突然出现了以前从未需要应对的情绪部分。好吧，这就是关于PMS的一些基础信息。让我们聊点别的。让我们聊聊PMS的——我不知道——那个愤怒的姐妹，经前期恶劣情绪障碍（PMDD）。所以，PMDD基本上是PMS的一种严重形式。它在人群中的出现率要低得多，大概（估计在2%到5%之间），但它极具破坏性。许多患有PMDD的人
You know, the first 10 years of you getting your period, you never noticed it. And now suddenly there are these emotional parts of this process that you never had to deal with before. Okay, so there's just some basic information about PMS. Let's talk about something else. Let's talk about PMS's, I don't know, angry assister, premenstrual, dysphoric disorder, PMDD. So, PMDD is basically a severe form of PMS. It shows up a lot less in the population around, you know, estimates are 2 to 5%, but it is extremely debilitating. A lot of people who have PMDD
将其描述为大脑中被拉动了一个开关，突然在经期前的一周或两周内，仿佛整个身体在一秒钟内被换成了别人的。你知道，她们前一秒可能还坐在餐桌旁感到非常满足、平静和快乐。然后转眼之间，她们就会感到排山倒海般的愤怒。她们会感到偏执、沮丧、深深的悲伤，比如挥之不去且无法改善的焦虑，
Describe it as being like a switch that gets flicked in their brain And suddenly in the week or, you know, two weeks before their period, Instantly, it's like their whole body has been switched with someone else's in a second. You know, they will go from sitting at the dinner table being completely content and peaceful and happy one second. And then in a click of their fingers, they feel overwhelming rage. they feel paranoia, frustration, deep sadness, like anxiety that won't go away and can't be improved,
这种感觉糟糕透顶，而就在它开始后不久，它又结束了。你知道，我实际上看到有人把她们的PMDD描述为每个月经历一次短暂的精神病。你知道，这对她们以及许许多多的人来说是一件既可怕又惊悚的事。正因为如此，有时它可能会导致误诊，有些情况下，人们被诊断出她们实际上并没有的极其严重的心理健康问题，但她们的PMDD症状的强度
and it feels awful and terrible, and then just as quickly as it started, it's over. You know, I actually saw someone describe PMDD in their case as like a temporary psychosis each month. You know, it's this scary and terrifying thing for them and for many, many people. And because of that, sometimes it can, lead to a misdiagnosis where there are cases of people being diagnosed with very extreme mental health conditions that they don't actually have, but the intensity of their PMDD symptoms
如此之高，以至于医生觉得找不到其他解释。如今，PMDD实际上在《精神疾病诊断与统计手册第五版》（DSM-5）中被归类为一种精神障碍。它属于抑郁障碍范畴，所以如果你愿意，可以得到正式的诊断，但要确定到底是PMDD还是其他某种形式的状况，绝对是一场挣扎。许多人向我解释说，实际上在她们被诊断出PMDD之前，她们曾被诊断患有焦虑症、精神分裂症、抑郁症。直到最后，有人问：“你觉得会不会是这个？”她们才终于有了答案。所以你在这个阶段可能会想，它真的和抑郁症或双相情感障碍有那么大区别吗？我们怎么能分辨出来？它们真的需要一个
are such that doctors feel like there are no other explanations. Nowadays, PMD is actually classified as a psychiatric disorder in the DSM-5. It's under the umbrella of depressive disorders, so you can get a formal diagnosis. if you wish, but it is definitely a struggle identifying whether it's PMDD or some other form of condition. And a lot of individuals have explained to me that actually before they were diagnosed with PMDD, they were diagnosed with anxiety, with schizophrenia, with depression. And then finally, someone said, do you think it's this? And they had their answer. So you might be thinking at this stage, well is it really all that different from depression or bipolar how can we tell and do they really need a
不同的诊断吗？是的，它们非常、非常不同。因为对于PMDD来说，抑郁、焦虑、边缘型人格障碍（BPD）或其他任何与之相似的病症的症状，只有在你处于周期的特定阶段时才会出现。而在此之后，它们几乎会完全消失。是的，有时个人可能会苦于应对那一周发生的事情所带来的余波，她们可能会觉得自己必须修复一些损害，或者只是对一切事物的强烈程度感到筋疲力尽。但这并不意味着她们的症状会持续整整四周，这意味着如果症状是由PMDD引起的，她们经历抑郁或焦虑的时间永远不会长到足以被诊断为
different diagnosis and yes they are very very different because with PMDD symptoms of depression of anxiety of BPD of whatever other condition in which there is of which there is a similarity they are only present when you are at a specific stage of your cycle but they will almost completely disappear afterwards. Yes, sometimes an individual may be struggling with the aftermath of what occurred during that week and they may feel like they have to repair some damages or they're just so tired from how intense everything was. But that doesn't mean that their symptoms are lasting for the entire four weeks, which means that they are never really in a period of depression or anxiety long enough if it's coming from PMDD for them to be classified with
除PMDD之外的其他任何疾病。现在，我想谈谈这个，因为我认为值得一提。有些人提出，经前期恶劣情绪障碍不应该被归类为精神障碍，因为它只是把正常的荷尔蒙波动病理化了，让女性看起来像疯子。当这场辩论出现并愈演愈烈时，医生、妇产科医生、精神科医生和心理学家写了数百上千封信，讨论
anything but PMDD. Now, I want to talk about this because I think it's important to note. Some people have suggested that premenstrual dysphoric disorder shouldn't be classified as a psychiatric disorder because it's just pathologizing normal hormonal fluctuations and it makes women seem crazy. And when that debate was around and coming up, there were hundreds and hundreds of letters written by doctors, OBGYN, psychiatrists, psychologists behind,
它是否应该被收录。其中一些论点非常站得住脚。比如，一些女性主义学者确实表示，它可能会被用来让女性闭嘴。它可能会助长癔症。一种传统的癔症心态。有些人说区分度还不够。但你知道吗？
whether or not it should or shouldn't have been included. Some of the arguments are very valid. Like, you know, some feminist scholars, they did say it could be used to silence women. It could feed into like a hysteria. a traditional hysteria mindset. Some people didn't say there wasn't enough differentiation. But you know what?
让人产生自杀倾向、无法下床或无法保住工作所需的荷尔蒙波动水平是不正常的。这并不是在把正常的事情病理化。一个诊断不仅具有验证性，而且是获得所需帮助的一种途径。它还能让人们感到被看到。并得到医学界的认可，因为她们拥有了一个感觉受到尊重的标签。如果我们能有一个正式的诊断，我们就可以开始看到PMDD的真正发病率，这也将有助于增加研究资金和提高意识，这是真的、真的很关键。
The level of hormonal fluctuations needed to occur to make someone suicidal or unable to leave bed or to keep a job is not normal. That's not pathologizing something normal. And a diagnosis is not only validating, but it is a way to get the help you need. It helps people also feel seen. and acknowledged by the medical community because they have some kind of label that feels respected. And if we can have a formal diagnosis, we can actually start seeing the true prevalence of PMDD, which also assists in increased research funding, increased awareness, which is really, really essential.
鉴于女性健康总体上受到的关注如此之少——比如针对男性秃顶的研究比多囊卵巢综合征（PCOS）和子宫内膜异位症加起来还要多——我认为，我们需要让女性健康问题获得更多的曝光度。最后再强调一次，PMDD和PMS是不同的。它们截然不同。而且PMDD要极端得多。所以如果PMS被列入DSM，我倒是能理解为什么人们会有意见。但PMDD是一种严重的疾病。PMS也是，但PMDD尤其需要大量的额外帮助。
And given how little attention female health gets in general, like there are more studies done on male baldness than PCOS and endometriosis combined. Like, I think we could do with a little bit more visibility for female health concerns. PMDD and PMS, just to say this one last time, though, they are different. They are very different. And PMDD is a lot more extreme. So if PMS was in the DSM, I would understand why people have issues. But PMDDD is a serious condition. PMS is as well, but PMDD in particular does require a lot of additional assistance.
所以我认为，拥有一个正确的诊断意味着许多女性将不再需要经历这样一种体验：去看医生并说：“我的生活感觉是这样的。在这样一个循环的过程中，一切似乎都在分崩离析。”而人们只是猜测：“哦，你只是在经前期综合征罢了。”然后让她们硬挺过去。洗个澡吧。就好像PMS本身是一件永远都很容易对付的事情。所以这里我还需要介绍另一个术语，它独立于PMS和PMDD，
So I think having a proper diagnosis means that a lot of women will no longer have to have the experience of going to the doctor saying, this is how my life feels. It feels like everything is falling apart in this cyclical way. And people just assuming, oh, you're just PMSing. They just push through it. Take a bath. As if PMS in itself is something that's always going to be easily manageable. So there's one more term I need to introduce here that's separate from PMS and. PMDD and it's called premenstrual exacerbation. So if you have an existing mental health condition
被称为经前期综合征加重（premenstrual exacerbation）。因此，如果你本来就存在心理健康状况，比如抑郁症、焦虑症、双相情感障碍，甚至像多动症（ADHD）这样的问题，你可能会注意到，与你平时的状态相比，在月经来临前夕，你的症状或病情会恶化。突然之间，你知道，你的焦虑水平达到了10级。你感到空虚。精神病性症状甚至也可能恶化。这并不是说你的症状只在那一周出现。它们一直存在，这与PMDD不同。只是在月经前夕，它们变得糟糕得多，也变得更加难以应对。
like depression, anxiety, bipolar disorder, even something like ADHD, you may notice that your symptoms or conditions get worse in the lead up to your period compared to what you're accustomed to. Suddenly, you know, your anxiety level is at a 10. You feel empty. Psychotic symptoms may even worsen as well. It's not that your symptoms are only occurring during that week. They're always present unlike PMDD. It's just that just before your period, they get so much worse and it becomes so much harder to deal with. So now that we're across these three distinct terms and conditions, let's go right back to PMS and talk about the why. What is responsible for the psychological changes, like sudden irritation, like trouble concentrating, like anxiety, brain fog, and then the secondary
既然我们已经了解了这三个截然不同的术语和状况，让我们直接回到PMS，谈谈“为什么”。是什么导致了这些心理变化，比如突然的烦躁、注意力难以集中、焦虑、脑雾，以及随之而来的羞耻感和“任何可见的情绪都会让你不被认真对待或不被尊重”的次生影响？这些都源于什么？所以这里我们需要非常熟悉两种荷尔蒙，你可能已经听说过它们，当然就是雌激素和孕激素。非常、非常常见。其实你可能在避孕药相关的内容中听说过它们，因为雌激素和孕激素本质上主要负责生殖、青春期、怀孕（如果你怀孕的话）、绝经、月经和你的生理周期。而你处于生理周期的哪个阶段，决定了这两种荷尔蒙的水平。
impact of shame and feeling like any kind of visible emotion will have you taken less seriously or respected less. Where does this come from? So there's two hormones we need to be really familiar with here and you've probably already heard of them, of course, estrogen and progesterone. Very, very common. You probably heard of them when it comes to your birth control actually because estrogen and progesterone, well, essentially they're primarily responsible for reproduction, for puberty, for pregnancy, if you do get pregnant, for menopause, for your period, for your cycle. And wherever you are in your period will determine the level of either of these hormones.
所以在排卵期间，雌激素通常非常高，这解释了为什么你的皮肤会发光、为什么你的头发会散发光彩、为什么你会感觉棒极了，因为更多的雌激素意味着更高的怀孕几率，所以在生物学上，你会想要吸引配偶。然而，在排卵后，孕激素水平急剧上升，而雌激素则下降，从而导致大量的生理和神经生物学变化。因此，研究人员已经表明，特别是孕激素水平的减少，确实会改变我们大脑的运作和感受方式。具体来说，它改变了我们处理和调节大脑中血清素水平的方式。所以血清素是快乐荷尔蒙，快乐化学物质。
So during ovulation, estrogen is typically very high, which contributes to why your skin is glowing, why your hair is radiant, why you feel incredible because more estrogen means greater chances of getting pregnant, so biologically you want to attract a mate. After ovulation, though, progesterone levels rise sharply while estrogen dips, leading to a lot of physiological and neurobiological changes. So, researchers have shown that particularly less progesterone in particular does change how our brain operates and feels. Particularly, it changes how we process and regulate levels of serotonin in the brain. So serotonin is the happy hormone, the happy chemical.
为了让它以适当的速率释放并在大脑内部以适当的速率被接收，需要达到一定水平的孕激素。当然，当这个水平在月经前下降时，那些习惯了特定孕激素水平的、负责释放血清素的既有系统突然就没有了那个水平。所以感觉就像是在一个已经被榨干的橙子上继续挤汁一样。我们需要了解的进一步信息和研究还表明，孕激素会影响大脑中的GABA受体，而GABA受体参与调节焦虑和情绪。所以如果你听过我们的焦虑那一集，你就会明白什么是GABA。GABA是我们大脑中的一种抑制剂。所以它能提供镇静效果。
And in order for it to be released at a proper rate and to be received at a proper rate inside the brain, a certain level of progesterone needs to be available. Now, of course, when that dips before our period, suddenly the systems in place that are releasing serotonin, which are used to a certain level of progesterone, no longer have that level. And so it feels like it's squeezing juice out of already juiced orange. Some further information and studies that we need to be aware of also indicate that progesterone influences the gabber receptors in the brain, which are involved in regulating anxiety and mood. So if you listen to our anxiety episode, you'll understand what Gabba is. Gabba is an inhibitor in our brain. So it provides a calming effect.
但如果孕激素在排卵后上升，然后在月经前夕稳步下降并自然下降，这意味着GABA受体与血清素受体一样，不再受到那么多的诱导或激活。所以我们对GABA的接收下降了，这意味着我们的焦虑感因此增加，因为具有兴奋作用的谷氨酸没有了它的平衡机制。基本上，我们需要GABA来保持冷静，但大脑只有在孕激素的帮助下才能读取GABA。所以当孕激素减少时，那些让我们感到自然焦虑的神经化学物质就不会受到调节，也不会遇到那么多的抵抗。现在，这就是造成PMS许多情绪和心理症状的原因。需要注意的是，这些荷尔蒙的变化是完全正常的。事实上，这是我们之前讨论过的那个生死循环的重要组成部分。
But if progesterone rises after ovulation and then steadily drops off right before our period and naturally drops, that means that GABA receptors, much like serotonin receptors, aren't being coaxed as much or activated as much. so our reception of Gabba declines, meaning that we are more anxious as a result, because glutamate, which has an exonerary effect, doesn't have its counterbalance. Basically, we need Gabba to stay calm, but Gabba can only be read by the brain with the help of progesterone. So when there's less, the neurochemicals that make us feel naturally anxious aren't being regulated or met with as much resistance. Now, this is what creates a lot of the emotional and psychological symptoms of PMS. Something to note, these hormonal changes, they're totally normal. In fact, it's an important part of that life and death cycle we talked about before.
所以你可能会问，如果这是正常的，为什么我感觉这么糟糕？为什么我们中的有些人，你知道，从未经历过PMS，而我们中的另一些人却有令人衰弱的PMDD症状？这种差异从何而来？好吧，根据《柳叶刀》（Lancet）在2009年左右发表的一项研究，患有PMS的女性，并不是她们的荷尔蒙变化得更快，而是她们对哪怕微小的荷尔蒙变化也具有更高的敏感性。正因为如此，对于某些人来说可以轻易被大脑忽略的事情，对她们来说感觉就像是一场全方位的心理、情绪和神经化学地震。从拥有特定水平的化学物质可用
So why is it you might be asking, if this is normal, why do I feel so terrible? And why is it that some of us, you know, never experience PMS, but others of us have debilitating PMDD symptoms. Like where does this variation come from? Well, according to a study published in the Lancet, back in I think 2009 actually, women with PMS, it's not that their hormones are changing more rapidly, it's that they have an increased sensitivity to even minute hormone changes. And because of this, what for some people would be easily dismissed by our brain, feels like an entire psychological, emotional, neurochemical earthquake. The shift from having certain levels of chemicals available
到仅仅拥有稍微少一点的荷尔蒙或化学物质可用，这种转变在某些人身上会被放大得厉害得多，而这特定的人群更有可能患上PMS和PMDD。这得到了《精神神经内分泌学》（Psychoneuroendocrinology）杂志上的另一篇综述的支持。在这篇论文中，作者提出，再次强调，导致PMS的并不是荷尔蒙波动。它们只是催化剂。关键在于它们是如何被处理的，以及我们的神经内分泌系统是如何解读这些信息的。
to having just even slightly less hormones or chemicals available feels a lot more magnified in certain people and those certain people are more likely to develop PMS and PMDD. This was backed by another review in psychoneuroctranolylogy. And in this journal, this paper suggested that, again, it's not hormonal fluctuations that cause PMS. They are just the catalyst. It's how they're processed and how our neuroendocrine system reads those messages.
信息是相同的。但有时我们体内负责解读这些信息的部分并不能很好地解读它们，从而导致了情绪和身体上的转变。有时，你知道，这只是因为你是这样出生的。这是你基因蓝图的一部分，很难解释，就像有些人需要眼镜一样。有些人的神经内分泌系统可能也需要一副“眼镜”，以便它能够正确地阅读、解释、理解和调节伴随着月经、伴随着你的月经周期而来的荷尔蒙变化。
The messages are the same. But sometimes the part of us that is meant to read these messages doesn't read them very well, causing those emotional and physical shifts. Sometimes, you know, it's just because that's how you were born. It's the part of your genetic blueprint that's difficult to explain the same way that some people need glasses. Some people's neuroendocrine system probably also needs glasses so that it can properly read, interpret, understand, regulate the hormonal changes that come with, you know, being on your period, that come with your menstrual cycle.
所以最大的理论是，导致严重PMS症状或PMDD的一个主要原因归结于基因，但还有其他因素参与其中。诸如创伤之类的情况实际上可以引发PMS的出现，无论是在早年生活还是在晚年生活。因此，我接下来要谈的这项研究在我第一次阅读时震撼了我的世界。我不认为我们可以经常这样评价关于基因异常和突变的研究。因为它们通常相当无聊。我不知道，也许你是个遗传学家，然后你会想：“不，这太迷人了。”但总的来说，阅读基因密码并不像是去游乐园。但关于PMDD的这一篇文章，我真的认为其中给出的解释可以改变生活。它是
So the biggest theory is that a large contributor to having severe PMS symptoms or PMDD does come down to genetics, but there's also something else involved. Circumstances like trauma can actually trigger the emergence of PMS both in early life and later in life. So the study I'm about to talk about blew my mind when I first read it. And I don't think we can say that often happens for studies about genetic irregularities and mutations. Like it's pretty much pretty boring. I don't know, maybe you're a geneticist and you're like, no, it's so fascinating. But in general reading about genetic codes, it's not like going to an amusement park. But this one article about PMDD, I really think like the explanation given in it could change lives. And it was
在2022年发表的。研究发现，我们许多人实际上含有一种特定的基因密码，会让我们预先倾向于患上PMDD。但它从未被激活。在我们大多数人身上，它处于休眠状态。所以我们不会继续发展出PMDD。但我们中的一些人就没有那么幸运了。而激活这个基因密码的是——嗯，是创伤。出于某种原因，创伤带来的压力和改变具有激活这种突变的影响。这是一种我们许多人都有的突变。但正如我所说，只有，你知道，我认为我们当中只有不到5%的人会被激活。
published in 2022. And it found that many of us actually contain a certain genetic code that would predispose us to PMDD. But it never gets switched on. In most of us, it lays dormant. So we don't go on to develop PMDD. But some of us are not so lucky. And what switches on this genetic code is, well, it's trauma. The stress and change of trauma for some reason has this impact of activating this mutation. And it's a mutation that a lot of us have. But like I said, only, you know, I think it's less than 5% of us in and us like it will ever be activated.
5%。在这项研究中，他们识别出了这个基因，并发现他们随机选择的PMDD患者样本中，有83%的女性经历过某种创伤。最常见的是早年生活创伤和情感虐待。现在，在PMDD女性群体中的这些比例，远高于一般人群中创伤的比例。你知道，人们说“身体会记住发生的一切”，在这种情况下，天哪，这是真的吗？我看到许多对这项研究做出反应的人都说：“我早就知道了。我知道我的身体运作方式有些不同。”我读过其中一个人的自述，她甚至谈到她的PMDD仅在经历了一段特别创伤的车祸关系后才开始。突然间，这个基因似乎被激活了。她在这次
5%. And in this study, they identified this gene, and they found that 83% of the women in their sample of randomly selected PMDD patients, they had experienced some kind of trauma. The most common being early life trauma and emotional abuse. Now, those rates in the circle of women with PMDD is so much higher than the rate of trauma in the general population. You know, they say the body keeps the score and in this case, oh my gosh, is it true? And I've seen so many people reacting to the study who have said, I knew it. I knew something was different about me in the way my body worked. One individual I read an account from, she even talked about how her PMDD only began after a particularly traumatic relationship in a car accident. And suddenly it seemed the gene was activated. She said in this, recount, like, I can see a distinct before and after. And researchers are still trying to get to the why of this all and understand this further.
叙述中说：“我可以清楚地看到前后区别。”研究人员仍在试图弄清楚这一切背后的“为什么”，并对此做进一步的理解。但我认为，对于许多长期经历PMDD或极度PMS的人来说，有时这个解释已经足够具有验证性了。有时你真的可以从中找到一些慰藉：你知道，这不是你的错。你的身体表现得不同，是超出了你的控制，是来自于过去，来自于发生在你身上的一些事情。所以，是的，这是基因易感性与环境的结合，使得PMS和PMDD尤其更有可能出现。我们还应该提及一些其他风险因素，包括吸烟、身体状况不佳，以及甲状腺问题，因为我们的甲状腺负责释放孕激素。所以如果它不正常，我们可能会遇到
But I think for a lot of people who have experienced PMDD or extreme PMS for a long time, sometimes this explanation is validating enough. Sometimes you can really find some solace in the fact that, you know, it wasn't you. that your body is behaving differently beyond your control and from the past, from something that occurred to you. So yes, it's a combination of predisposition, but also environment that it makes PMS and PMDD specifically more likely to emerge. There are some other risk factors that we should mention, including smoking, poor physical health, but also thyroid problems, because our thyroid is responsible for the release of progestrone. And so if it's not functioning, we may encounter
问题。这很大程度上又回到了我们的神经内分泌系统。你知道，你会看到很多诸如“这是因为你的饮食”、“这是因为这个和那个”、“你没有服用正确的补充剂”之类的内容。我认为实际上这要复杂得多。如果之前的研究能说明什么的话，那就是它与发生在我们身上的许多事情有关，而不是与我们对自己的身体主动做了什么有关。所以我真的不喜欢那种把PMS或PMDD归咎于女性不良生活方式的叙述，仿佛这是它发生的原因，而你只要轻轻松松改变生活方式，这一切就会
problems. A lot of this is coming back to our neuroendocrine system. And you know, you do see a lot of stuff being like, it's because of your diet, and it's because of this and that and you're not taking the right supplements and all these things. I think that actually it's a lot more complex than that. And if that previous study had anything to say, like it links back to so many things that happen to us rather than things that we are actively doing to ourselves. So I really don't like this narrative that blames women who have PMS or PMDD with poor lifestyle choices. And that's why it's occurring and you could so easily change your lifestyle and it would all
烟消云散。事实绝对并非如此。这种说法中大概只有5%到10%的真实性。希望这个解释对你来说有一定的意义。它让你对身体表面之下那些非常隐秘的运作机制有了更多的清晰认识。我们现在要休息一下。但当我们回来时，我们将讨论有科学依据的建议、在你的周期的哪个时间做出决定是最好的、
fall away for you. That's definitely not the case. Maybe only about 5, 10% of truth in that statement. So hopefully this explanation makes some kind of sense to you. It's given you more clarity over very invisible workings in your body below the surface. We are going to take a quick break right now. But when we return, we are going to talk science-back tips, when in your cycle is the best time to make decisions,
如何管理与PMS或PMDD相关的无益感觉和想法，以及更多、更多内容。所以请继续收听。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中。我将剖析精神坚韧、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，
how to manage unhelpful feelings and thoughts associated with PMS or PMDD, and so, so much more. So please stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more,
超越那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾深信种子油生来就会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上大惊小怪的许多问题，都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会在另一面成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上拍打莉儿·金（Lil Kim）的胸部吗？或者坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。
to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.
去无视那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力造成的。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你将在另一边成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听 2%。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在 VMA 颁奖典礼上双击了小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。
What the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at It podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know.
乔治·布什跟一点点小杀戮到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在 Look Back at It 播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会在这里切入正题，剖析发生的事情，并试着理清我们是如何熬过那段日子的。包括最近一集请来了马克·拉蒙特·希尔，大谈80年代的可卡因。把话说清楚，84年对我意义重大，不只是因为可卡因。我随时都可以聊聊可卡因，不过只是想让大家知道。
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed cracks. I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集了。我开始看出这里面有一条贯穿始终的线索了。我们现在还讨论了艾滋病。谢谢你帮我把话说完。是的。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking.
对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。请在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Look Back at It。欢迎收听我的新播客《狠狠吸取教训》（Learn the Hardway），我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是。
Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses.
特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时候，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于投入追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它，却还在继续追逐，我们不知道什么时候才算够，因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了关于赢和输。
Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way.
史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，你觉得在世期间做一个好人重要吗？你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是的。这也是两种不同的信任水平。我希望你纯粹是因为想做一个好人。加入我基尔·盖恩斯的全新播客《狠狠吸取教训》，我们将在节目中就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。
Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself. at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth.
打开你的免费 iHeartRadio App。搜索 Learn the Hardway 并立即收听。2023年，前《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家事法院听证会暴露出她谎言中明显的前后矛盾。这开启了长达数年的诉讼之战，以证明真相。
You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.
你对这个特定的测试作假了两次，对吧？我只对测试作假了一次。这需要一支互联网侦探大队才能破解这个案子。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税都被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. The West B and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges.
另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。韦斯特·B 和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的天呐。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，
This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Dealing with PMS and PMDD was described to me by a listener as Sisyphus pushing his rock up the hill. Every month you have to deal with the same roller coaster. Every month it feels like you are at the behest of some hidden emotional forces and it's frustrating and it's exhausting and it feels like it will never be over and never be okay. sometimes there's even an anger there anger at your body for doing what it's meant to do but being so inconvenient about it you know it doesn't seem to care about your life or your professional engagements
马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听 Love Trapped 播客。经听众形容，应对经前期综合征（PMS）和经前期烦躁症（PMDD）就像西西弗斯推石头上山一样。每个月你都得应对同样的过山车。每个月你都会觉得自己受制于某种隐藏的情绪力量，这让人沮丧，让人筋疲力尽，感觉永远不会结束，也永远不会好起来。有时候甚至会产生愤怒，对自己的身体感到愤怒，因为它在做它该做的事，却又偏偏选在一个这么不凑巧的时候，你知道的，它似乎根本不在乎你的生活、你的工作安排
or your plans or your relationship or your mental stability none of the above that coupled with the fact that you know well we've spoken about this already but the medical system in general takes health problems typically associated with women and likes to ignore them for as long as possible and be dismissive and say you're overreacting or have you tried exercise or two padenols should do the trick, you know, that on top of it makes it even more tricky. There's also this sense that if you have PMS, if you are struggling with an emotional tidal wave, you better conceal that. You better keep that way down, especially in the workplace, especially around people who won't understand because you don't want to be seen as hysterical,
、你的计划、你的恋情或你的心理稳定，统统不在乎。再加上这样一个事实：你知道的，虽然我们已经讨论过这个了，但医疗系统总体上往往会把通常与女性相关的健康问题尽可能长时间地忽视掉，并表现得不屑一顾，说你反应过度了，或者你试过运动吗，或者吃两片扑热息痛就搞定了，你知道的，再加上这些，就让情况变得更加棘手了。还有这样一种感觉：如果你有经前期综合征，如果你正在与情绪海潮作斗争，你最好把情绪藏起来。你最好把它压抑下去，尤其是在职场中，尤其是在那些无法理解的人周围，因为你不想被视为歇斯底里，
you don't want to be seen as weak. You don't want to be seen as too emotional because our society has really devalued specific traits that appear associated or are associated with being a woman. So that is definitely the cherry on top that none of us asked for. With all that in mind, though, I wanted to bring together, yes, some of the best advice I could find for how to help yourself psychologically and mentally for that period where your brain feels like it has been switched with someone else's and some
你不想被视为软弱。你不想被视为过于情绪化，因为我们的社会确实贬低了那些看似与女性相关或被认为与女性特质相关的特定特征。所以这绝对是锦上添花，不过是没人想要的那种。尽管如此，考虑到所有这些，我还是想把能找到的最好建议汇集在一起，帮助你在大脑感觉像是被调包、某些
wires across without you knowing. How can you do more than just wait it out? A philosophy I have in my life is that the more you know, the less you can be misled. When it comes to our bodies, that has never been more true. Now, I don't want you to misconstrue my words and say like, oh, you shouldn't get advice from a doctor. like you if you've read 20 books about PMS you know more than a specialist like not the case it's obviously great to educate yourself and to know more but we're specifically talking about knowing
电线错位却浑然不知的那段时期，从心理和精神上帮助自己。你该如何不仅仅是熬过去呢？我人生中的一个信条是：你知道得越多，你就越不容易被误导。当谈到我们的身体时，这句话从来没有像现在这样正确。现在，我不希望你曲解我的话，说什么“哦，你不应该听从医生的建议”。就像如果你读了20本关于经前期综合征的书，你就比专家懂得还多，情况并非如此。通过自我教育了解更多知识显然是一件很好的事情，但我们具体讨论的是更好地了解
your own body better so if you have been struggling with PMS the best thing you can do is start keeping a feelings and emotions journal or app tracker any form of i don't know information gathering when it comes to your symptoms. You know, that can be synced up to your period app if you use one, but also separately. The app that I love is called MindDoc and it's incredible. It basically offers you check-ins and helps you to identify emotional patterns in this really cool mathematical, graphical, visual way.
你自己的身体。因此，如果你一直在与经前期综合征做斗争，你能做的最好的事情就是开始记录感受和情绪日记，或者使用应用追踪器，任何形式的、我不知道的、关于你症状的信息收集。你知道的，这可以与你的经期应用同步（如果你有的话），也可以单独记录。我喜欢的一款应用叫 MindDoc，它太棒了。它基本上为你提供打卡功能，并以这种非常酷的数学、图表、可视化的方式帮助你识别情绪模式。
So if you're a visual processor, if having a visual map of how you're feeling on certain days over a period of time, be helpful, that is definitely a good option for you. But I also find it really, really validating even just to journal about it. And I find it validating because I'm able to say through noticing these patterns, oh, okay, this is linked to a known part of my cycle where I feel terrible. I don't need to beat myself up over this the way that I have been doing. I know it will pass. I don't need to think that it's going to last forever. This happens every month, and I know it because here is my information.
所以，如果你是一个视觉型处理者，如果有一张关于你在一段时间内特定日期的情绪感受的视觉地图会对你有所帮助，那这绝对是一个不错的选择。但我同时也发现，仅仅是将它写成日记，就已经能起到非常非常强大的验证作用了。我之所以觉得它有验证作用，是因为通过注意到这些模式，我能够说：“哦，好吧，这与我周期中感觉糟糕的已知部分有关。”我不需要像以前那样因为这件事而自我苛责。我知道它会过去的。我不需要认为它会永远持续下去。这种事每个月都会发生，而且我很清楚，因为这里有我的信息。
You know, sometimes our lives are so busy and hectic and overstimulating that we fall out of sync with how our body feels. And so when things do come up, headaches, mood swings, hormonal changes, anchor, we feel shocked and stressed by it because we haven't been expecting it because we haven't been paying attention to where we are in the cycle of our periods, where we are in our bodies at any given moment. So it's really, really important that if you're struggling to get more information about the cycles presenting in your body than you already have.
你知道的，有时我们的生活太忙碌、太狂热、接受了太多刺激，以至于我们与身体的感受失去了同步。因此，当事情真的出现时——头痛、情绪波动、荷尔蒙变化、愤怒，我们会感到震惊和压力，因为我们没有预料到，因为我们没有关注我们在经期循环中的位置，没有关注我们在任何给定时刻身体的状态。所以，如果你正在挣扎，去获取比你现在拥有的更多的、关于你身体呈现出的周期的信息，这是非常非常重要的。
My next tip is to focus on sleep hygiene. So I interviewed a doctor recently for the show, Dr. Mark Hyman, and his episode is coming out very, very soon, but something he said to, to me that has become a fixation point of mind in the last however many days is that if he have to go back to 20 and tell himself one piece of advice, it would be to sleep more. And if you have PMS or PMDD in particular, the studies have shown time and time again. Seven to nine hours every night is not an option. It's an essential. And it's what your body needs to be able to restore itself. And it definitely needs that during your ludial phase,
我的下一个建议是专注于睡眠卫生。所以我最近为节目采访了一位医生，马克·海曼医生，他的单集节目很快就会上线，但他对我说的一句话——在过去的许多天里成为了我关注的焦点——那就是：如果他能回到20岁并给自己一条建议，那就是多睡觉。如果你有经前期综合征，特别是经前期烦躁症，研究一次又一次地表明。每晚睡七到九个小时不是可选项。这是必需的。这是你的身体为了能够自我修复所需要的东西。尤其在你的黄体期，它绝对需要这个，
when your cells and your mind and your uterus and your whole body is under even more stress. You're probably thinking, yeah, okay, whatever, great advice. I'm busy, I've heard it before, I've tried that. To which I say, please try again, because which discomfort is worse to you? The discomfort of not having, you know, a few extra 30 minutes of screen time before bed or finding it harder to regulate your emotions. sleep hygiene is so important here are like three really simple ways you can do that really low effort that i just need you to try i've tried they work like a charm number one i need you to get an old-fashioned
那时你的细胞、你的思维、你的子宫和你的整个身体都承受着更大的压力。你可能在想：“行吧，好吧，随便啦，好建议。我很忙，我以前听过了，我试过了。”对此我想说：请再试一次，因为哪种不适对你来说更糟糕？是没有在睡前多玩30分钟手机带来的不适，还是发现自己更难调节情绪？睡眠卫生在这里非常重要。这里有三种非常简单、只需极低努力你就可以做到的小方法，我只需要你去尝试，我都试过了，它们像魔咒一样灵验。第一点，我需要你买一个老式的
alarm clock number two i need you to keep your phone out of your room number three don't watch tv or movies or whatever else on your laptop ipad phone in your bed all of these help create a distinction between the spaces and the times when you are meant to be awake and alert and the times when you are meant to be restful and sleeping. And this change costs you the price of an alarm clock from a $2 store. And it could even help you live longer, if not make your PMS feel more manageable. I would also say try and create a soft, gentle routine for yourself during that week or that period for you of intense symptoms. Now what does that look like?
闹钟。第二点，我需要你把手机放在卧室外面。第三点，不要在床上用笔记本电脑、iPad或手机看电视、电影或任何其他东西。所有这些都有助于在时间和空间上划清界限：哪些时间是应该保持清醒和警觉的，哪些时间是应该休息和睡觉的。而这个改变只需要你花两美元在商店买一个闹钟的钱。它甚至能帮你延年益寿，即便不能让你的经前期综合征感觉更好管理。我还想说，在那周或你经历强烈症状的时期，试着为自己建立一个温柔、舒缓的常规。那会是什么样的呢？
That needs to look like. Less intense socializing. Less drinking, hopefully zero drinking. More working from home if you can. Less jeans, more leggings. Give yourself the gift of 10 more minutes to get ready in the morning. 10 more minutes to slow down at night to get places on time. Prioritize less activities during your day.
它需要是这样的：减少密集的社交。减少饮酒，最好是零饮酒。如果可以的话，更多地在家办公。少穿牛仔裤，多穿打底裤。在早晨给自己多留10分钟的准备时间。在晚上给自己多留10分钟慢下来的时间，以便按时到达目的地。在白天减少不必要的活动。
Now, this last one is huge for me because I don't know if you can relate to this, but as someone who is, you know, I would say has some high achiever perfectionist tendencies, giving myself just a break from a big schedule, a high load schedule, is very, very difficult. But, you know, literally the other day I went to a Pilates class and I was in such a bad mood. I was just, you know, I had all these PMS symptoms. And halfway through, I was just feeling so irritated. And I left. I got up.
现在，最后这一点对我有巨大意义，因为我不知道你能不能感同身受，但作为一个……怎么说呢，我有一些高成就导向的完美主义倾向，仅仅是给自己一个大日程安排、高负荷日程安排的暂停，都是非常非常困难的。但是，你知道的，就在前几天我去上普拉提课，我当时心情糟糕透顶。我只是，你知道的，我身上有所有这些经前期综合征的症状。上到一半，我感到非常烦躁。然后我离开了。我站起身来。
I said, thank you to the teacher. I was like, it's not you. It's me. And I went away. I went away and I went home and I just got into bed because that's what my body was calling for me to do. Even if my mind wanted me to be more efficient or productive. I find really that my capacity to do more and even my capacity to be around others declines right before my period. I find that I don't have the same bandwidth to be present,
我对老师说谢谢。我说：“不是你的问题。是我的问题。”然后我离开了。我离开了，回到家里，直接钻进了被窝，因为那是我的身体在呼唤我去做的事。即便我的思维希望我更有效率、更有生产力。我确实发现，就在经期到来之前，我做更多事情的能力，甚至是我和他人相处的能力都在下降。我发现自己没有同样的带宽去保持在场，
to reciprocate energy-wise, to monitor others' emotions, to deal with my own frustrations. I have less space for empathy because I am so irritated and there's normally a lot on my mind. Now, this has nothing to do with the other person. They're just existing. It is everything to do with me and how wired and raw my nerves feel, which can just make me, I'm sure I'm pleasant to be around and it makes me feel more drained. So going slowly means subtracting rather than adding things onto my plate during a time when I know stress is going to be heightened for me. And even sometimes avoiding things that I would typically find enjoyable just for a few days for some solo time. Also, you need to be dilly-dallying more.
在能量上进行回应，去监控他人的情绪，去处理我自己的挫折感。我留给共情空间变小了，因为我太烦躁了，而且通常脑子里装了很多事情。现在，这与另一个人无关。他们只是存在着。这完全与我有关，与我的神经感觉到的紧绷和敏感有关，这只会让我——我确信——变得很难相处，而且让我感到更加精疲力竭。所以，放慢节奏意味着在我明知自己的压力将会加剧的时期，选择做减法，而不是往我的盘子里添加更多事情。甚至有时候，仅仅为了独处一段时间，而故意避开那些我平时觉得很享受的事情几天。此外，你需要更多地磨蹭。
You need to be less rushed towards. certain goals or certain chores of getting things done, especially during this period. I need you to just relish the act of slowing down, of being more present, of walking around without music in your ears, without too many freaking, what are they called, tote bags on you, trying to get from one place to the other feeling completely overwhelmed. We are about softness, we are about slowing down, we are about long-term sustainability and self-sufficiency rather than burning way too bright, way too fast. Also, another part of this is just focus on low-impact exercises because there have been studies,
你需要减少对某些目标或某些琐事的匆忙追赶，特别是对把事情做完的急切，尤其是在这段时期。我需要你去细细品味放慢脚步的行为，去享受更多的当下，去在耳朵里不听音乐、身上不挂着太多莫名其妙的——它们叫什么来着——帆布包的情况下四处走动，而不必为了从一个地方赶到另一个地方而感到彻底崩溃。我们主张柔软，我们主张慢下来，我们主张长期的可持续性和自给自足，而不是燃烧得太亮、太快。另外，这其中的另一个部分是专注于低冲击运动，因为已经有研究表明，
including one from 2024, that have suggested that things like kit workouts actually spike progesterone and then cause it to, as a counterbalance, rapidly decline later on, which we know will end up impacting GABA levels and lead to more anxiety, which is already at a low during the stage of the cycle. So take your rest days, go for a long walk instead. You don't need to push yourself when your body is asking for rest. In fact, it's demanding rest. You've got to lean into what each period of your cycle actually calls for you to do
包括一项2024年的研究表明，像 HIIT（高强度间歇训练）这样的训练实际上会使孕酮激增，然后作为一种平衡机制，随后导致其迅速下降，我们知道这最终会影响 GABA（γ-氨基丁酸）水平，并导致更多的焦虑，而焦虑在这个周期的阶段已经处于较低水平了。所以，请好好休息，去散个长步吧。当你的身体要求休息时，你不需要强迫自己。事实上，它正在强烈要求休息。你必须顺应你周期的每个阶段实际要求你去做的事，
based on the instincts of your body and where you're going to seek comfort. This is also more of a behavioral tip, but don't make any big, decisions during this time. Consider them, make a plan for them, don't act until you feel clear-headed. Now, this isn't to say that women are hysterical and not to be trusted because their period makes them do crazy hysterical things. Like, no, that's quite a harmful narrative. I just think on a personal level, you want to know when your brain, specifically your emotional brain, is going to be at it's best. You want to know when your brain is going to be most capable and smart and really hone in on those times to make big decisions, to question big things. When you're on your period
基于你身体的本能以及你将去哪里寻求慰藉。这也是一个更多偏向行为层面的小贴士，但在这段期间不要做任何重大的决定。去权衡它们，为它们制定一个计划，在你的头脑感觉清醒之前不要采取行动。现在，这并不是说女性歇斯底里、不可信任，因为她们的经期会让她们做出疯狂歇斯底里的行为。不，那是一种相当有害的叙事。我只是认为，在个人层面上，你会希望了解你的大脑——特别是你的情感大脑——什么时候会处于最佳状态。你会希望了解你的大脑什么时候最能干、最聪明，并真正锁定那些时间来做出重大决定、去质疑重要的事情。当你处在经期
or right before, it's just going to be all wrapped up in additional anxiety and stress and tension. And I think it's not going to help you feel confident in the decision, even if it's the right one. So know when to trust your instincts versus understand that something is an impulse and structure decision making and planning around those peaks and troughs of your cycle and of your mental state. I think handling PMS or PMDD is all about just ease and the path of least resistance and what's going to make things simpler for you when your mind and your body is feeling chaotic. I also would suggest you think about getting professional help and not just from your family doctor but someone who really knows what they're talking about there are so many more treatments now you don't need to despair over your PMS or your PMDD taking over your life there are so many more options and just
或者经期到来之前，这一切都只会夹杂着额外的焦虑、压力和紧张。我认为这不会帮助你对这个决定感到自信，哪怕它是正确的决定。所以，要懂得何时相信你的直觉，又要明白什么时候只是一种冲动，并围绕你周期的波峰波谷以及你的精神状态来构建决策和规划。我认为应对经前期综合征或经前期烦躁症的关键就在于轻松、走阻力最小的路线，以及当你的大脑和身体感到混乱时，什么能让事情变得更简单。我也建议你考虑寻求专业帮助，不仅是找你的家庭医生，而是找真正懂行的人。现在有这么多的治疗方法，你不需要对经前期综合征或经前期烦躁症接管你的生活感到绝望，有这么多的选项，只要
organizing a time where you can go and learn about some of those hear what someone else has to say about your condition maybe even be validated in what you've been experiencing is So, so important. Some final two tips. If you have a partner, invite them to share your period app details or like invite them to follow along for you. I don't know. Like what is it? Like join your cycle app.
安排一个时间，去了解其中的一些方法，听听别人对你的状况有什么看法，甚至从别人的视角来印证你一直在经历的事情，这是非常非常重要的。最后两个小建议。如果你有伴侣，邀请他们共享你的经期应用详情，或者邀请他们一起关注。我不知道。这叫什么？加入你的周期应用。
Join your cycle up so they can see peaks and troughs understand when to bring up arguments, when to bring up small things better for both of you so that you're not constantly in a state of conflict. I also sometimes do this with my friends. You just understand each other better. You know what the other person needs. You can mediate and moderate conversation and expectations and communication and plans so much better. When you do just have a more in depth understanding of what everyone's current emotional capacity and emotional state is like. And have empathy for yourself.
加入你的周期应用，这样他们就能看到波峰和波谷，明白什么时候该挑起争端，什么时候该聊聊小事，这对你们两个都更好，这样你们就不会总是处于冲突状态了。我有时也会和朋友这样做。你们能更好地理解彼此。你知道对方需要什么。你们可以更好地调解和缓和对话、期望、沟通和计划。当你对每个人当前的情感容量和情感状态有了更深入的了解时。对自己多一点同理心。
You know, your body is so complex. Like it's one of the most complex things to exist. and there is nobody in the world who can possibly understand every single reaction and thing that goes on below the surface that you are forced to feel. Like PMS dials every single tiny reaction up to 100 and has you feel them all at once. And it's tricky and it's hard. It's also something that others are going through and you can find the light in it. There are so many more resources, so many more ways,
你知道，你的身体太复杂了。它就像是存在的最复杂的事物之一。世界上没有人能够完全理解隐藏在水面之下、迫使你去感受的每一个反应和发生的事情。就像经前期综合征把每一个微小的反应都调到了100，让你同时感受到所有这些。这很棘手，也很艰难。这也是其他人正在经历的事情，你可以在其中找到光明。有这么多的资源，这么多的方法，
and opportunities to be open in our communication, to talk about it, and to make this condition, both PMS and PMDD, more visible and not a weakness, just in addition to our lives that we have to navigate as expertly as possible. Okay, we're going to take one more quick break, and then when we return, we are going to move on to our listener questions. If you aren't familiar with this segment of the show, because it is relatively new, a couple months ago, I started inviting listeners to ask their own personal questions when it comes to our topics just to make sure that we cover what people are actually interested in and some of the
有更多的机会在沟通中保持开放，去谈论它，让这种状况——无论是经前期综合征还是经前期烦躁症——变得更加显眼，而不是一种软弱，而只是我们生活中必须尽可能熟练应对的一部分。好了，我们再休息一下，等我们回来后，我们将进入听众提问环节。如果你对节目的这个环节不太熟悉，因为它相对较新，几个月前，我开始邀请听众针对我们的主题提出他们自己的个人问题，只是为了确保我们涵盖了人们真正感兴趣的内容，以及你们可能对我们提出的一些
more niche questions that you may have for us. So we are going to take a quick little pause. And when we return, we have some juicy questions, some great questions from my lovely, lovely listeners. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are
更加小众的问题。所以我们要稍作暂停。当我们回来时，我会有一些精彩的问题，来自我可爱、可爱的听众们的很棒的问题。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了坚韧意志、体能训练以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康与健身专家等人对话，带大家看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾以为种子油本身就会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，
freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What? The hell does George Bush got to do a little count? Well, you can find out on The Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jay.
其实都是压力的结果。经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听《2%》（2%）。可以在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在 VMA 颁奖典礼上拍打小姬姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟一个小账户到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰伊。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now.
我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会在这里切入正题，剖析发生的事情，并试着理清我们是如何熬过那段日子的。包括最近一集请来了马克·拉蒙特·希尔，大谈80年代的可卡因。把话说清楚，84年对我意义重大，不只是因为可卡因。我随时都可以聊聊可卡因，不过只是想让大家知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集了。所以我开始看出这里面有一条贯穿始终的线索了。我们现在还讨论了艾滋病。
Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, care games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month,
谢谢你帮我把话说完。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。请在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Look Back at It。欢迎收听我的新播客《狠狠吸取教训》（Learn the Hardway），我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，
I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing
我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时候，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于投入追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它，
and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro.
却还在继续追逐，我们不知道什么时候才算够，因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了关于赢和输。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，你觉得在世期间做一个好人重要吗？或者你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。
Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now.
绝对是的。这也是两种不同的信任水平。我希望你纯粹是因为想做一个好人。加入我基尔·盖恩斯的全新播客《狠狠吸取教训》，我们将在节目中就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你的免费 iHeartRadio App。搜索 Learn the Hardway 并立即收听。
In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd, found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones.
2023年，前《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家事法院听证会暴露出她谎言中明显的前后矛盾。这开启了长达数年的诉讼之战，以证明真相。你对这个特定的测试作假了两次，对吧？我只对测试作假了一次。
It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through, the same thing. Greg, the lesbian,
这需要一支互联网侦探大队才能破解这个案子。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税都被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，莱斯利，
Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen,
迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的天呐。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，
breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Traped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts,
马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方
or wherever you get your podcasts. The listener questions this week were so good. They were so amazing. I was very intrigued to dig a little bit of deeper into what you guys want to know. We're going to start with this question, which I found so fascinating. How would PMS interact with ADHD? So I consulted some really interesting articles about this, specifically a paper from
收听 Love Trapped 播客。这周的听众提问太棒了。太精彩了。我很想深入探讨一下你们想了解的内容。我们从这个问题开始，我觉得这个问题非常引人入胜。经前期综合征（PMS）与多动症（ADHD）是如何相互作用的呢？所以我查阅了一些关于这个话题非常有趣的文章，特别是2023年的一篇论文。
23. And what it suggested is that having ADHD and PMS is, and this is literally their words, this is a direct quote from this article, a double whammy. Whereby symptoms of ADHD are more likely to increase when estrogen levels drop. So right as your period starts and just before.
它表明，患有多动症同时又有经前期综合征——这绝对是他们的原话，这是这篇文章的直接引述——是一个“双重打击”。即当雌激素水平下降时，多动症的症状更有可能加剧。也就是在经期开始时和经期前夕。
In particular, they found two things happen. There is an increase in approach slash risk-taking behaviors, but more so an increase in avoidance and negative effect. So negative mood, but also in attention symptoms. So if you're finding that your ADHD is getting worse before your period, you are not mistaken. It's a real thing. And they also noted, and I'm glad they did, that the pressure to mask your ADHD or appear functional is also a lot more prominent and stronger in work. women. And so it sometimes feels that you have to suppress or conceal two things at once. You know, you have to suppress your ADHD symptoms even though you feel more agitated and you feel
特别是，他们发现两件事会发生。接近/冒险行为会有所增加，但更多的是回避和消极情绪的增加。也就是消极情绪，以及注意力不集中症状的增加。所以，如果你发现你的多动症在经期前变得更严重了，你并没有感觉错。这是一个真实存在的现象。他们还指出——我很高兴他们指出了这一点——掩饰多动症或表现得功能正常的压力在职场女性中也更加突出和强烈。因此，有时你会觉得你必须同时压抑或掩盖两件事。你知道的，你必须压抑你的多动症症状，即使你感到更加烦躁，并且你觉得
like they are stronger. But you also don't want to be seen as overly emotional. So you have to either consciously or unconsciously ignore your PMS symptoms as well. I know that probably paints a very bleak picture, but I think that information is so valuable to know because you can just say to self. This is not me. Like, it's not just me. It's not because I'm too sensitive or weak or because I lack discipline. It's because of this so-called double whammy, this hormonal influence on my mental state and my capacity to pay attention, to focus, to control my impulses. So I would really recommend reading this article. It's called Attention Deficit slash Hyperactivity Disorder and the menstrual cycle theory and evidence from the journal of
它们更加强烈。但你又不想被视为过于情绪化。所以你不得不有意识或无意识地也忽略你的经前期综合征症状。我知道这可能描绘了一幅非常惨淡的画卷，但我认为这些信息非常有价值，因为你可以对自己说：“这不是我。这不只是我。这不是因为我太敏感、软弱或缺乏自律。”这是因为所谓的“双重打击”，这种荷尔蒙对我的精神状态、注意力、专注力以及冲动控制能力的影响。所以我强烈建议阅读这篇文章。它发表在《荷尔蒙与行为》杂志上，标题是《注意缺陷/多动障碍与月经周期：理论与证据》。实际上它也是免费获取的。如果你是一名心理学专业的学生或经常阅读大量学术论文的人，你就会知道，当某样东西是免费的，当你有一篇开放获取的论文时，就像美梦成真一样。所以别找借口了。去读一读吧。我认为它相当具有验证性，也相当具有启发性。
of hormones and behavior. It's actually also free access as well. And if you're a psychology student or someone who accesses a lot of academic papers, you'll know that when something's free, when you haven't like an open access paper, it's like a dream come true. So there's no excuses. Go give it a read. I think it will be quite validating, quite illuminating as well.
（接上条：也相当具有启发性。）
Okay. The second question we got was, how do I navigate early dating during PMS? Now, this is tough because we talked about how. how PMS sometimes promotes, encourages, creates a lot of interpersonal tension, just because we are coming to the table, feeling a little bit different in ourselves, perhaps less patient, perhaps more sensitive. And so when you first started dating someone, sometimes you don't always want to present that version of yourself that maybe you feel
好了。我们收到的第二个问题是：在经前期综合征期间，我该如何应对早期的约会？现在，这很艰难，因为我们讨论过经前期综合征如何。经前期综合征有时是如何促进、鼓励、制造大量的人际紧张关系的，仅仅是因为我们来到台前时，对自己的感觉有点不同，也许不那么有耐心，也许更敏感。所以当你刚开始和某人约会时，有时你并不总是想展现出连你自己都可能感到
a little bit ashamed of. You have no reason to, but maybe you're like, oh, you know, dating is anxiety-inducing enough than put in my PMS or my PMDD symptoms and like it's just a freaking hurricane of, of a reactivity and not knowing what's going to happen. So I think you have two options based on how you want to go about it. The first path is slow and cautious. The second is all in. So with the first path, we are going to consciously take back time for ourselves during our period and not communicate why that is with.
有点羞耻的那部分自己。你完全没有理由羞耻，但也许你会想：“哦，你知道的，约会本身就已经够让人焦虑的了，再加上我的经前期综合征或经前期烦躁症症状，简直就像是一场狂暴的情绪反应飓风，完全不知道会发生什么。”所以我认为根据你想采取的方式，你有两种选择。第一条路径是缓慢而谨慎。第二条是全力以赴。对于第一条路径，我们将有意识地在经期为自己留出时间，并且不将原因告知
someone else. So if they're not your partner, if it's early dating, you might not want to let them in. You might not want them to know what is going on because dating can be stressful. PMS can be stressful, especially if you are worried about someone's approval or judgment of it. So only engage with this person when you feel like it. Try and pull back a little bit for that period just for your own self-care, but also remember that you can't say the wrong thing to the right person. They will understand, they will reciprocate or give, you know, give you grace and be generous and kind if you do tell them. And that is option two.
其他人。所以如果他们还不是你的伴侣，如果只是早期约会，你可能不想让他们介入。你可能不想让他们知道发生了什么，因为约会可能会有压力。经前期综合征可能会有压力，特别是如果你担心某人对它的认可或判断。所以只有在你觉得想这样做时才与这个人互动。在那段时期试着稍微退一步，纯粹为了自我照顾，但也要记住，你对对的人永远不会说错话。如果你告诉他们，他们会理解，会回应，或者给你包容、慷慨和善良。这就是选项二。
Option one, you tell them later down the line, you spend those first three months, you know, managing your PMS on your own as you have been accustomed to, or you can just be up front. You can be straight up and just say, hey, I'm going to be. kind of out for the account this week. I've got really bad PMS and I don't really want to be around people. Is that okay? Do you understand? It's probably a very good litmus test as well as to whether someone will make a good partner if they can respond positively or appropriately to you telling them about this medical condition you have and how it makes your life more difficult. Okay, question number three, why do I want to rage at everyone? I mentioned this a couple times, but we didn't speak about
选项一，你稍后告诉他们，你花头那三个月，（你知道的，）像往常一样自己应对经前期综合征，或者你可以开诚布公。你可以直截了当地说：“嘿，这周我可能不太方便露面。我有很严重的经前期综合征，我真的不想跟人待在一起。这样可以吗？你理解吗？”这也是一个非常好的试金石，用来检验当一个人对你所患的这种医疗状况以及它是如何让你的生活变得更艰难做出积极或适当的反应时，他是否能成为一个好伴侣。好了，问题三：为什么我对每个人都想发火？我之前提到过好几次，但我们没有深入讨论，
it in depth, which is totally an oversight for me because rage, anger, frustration, fury is a huge component of PMS. Why is it this case? Well, estrogen in particular plays, obviously as we know, a key role in supporting serotonin, which is the happy hormone also helps stabilize our mood. So estrogen drops, serotonin drops, mood swings, low patients, irritability all ensue. At times as well, because progesterone induces a calming effect when that is lower, you know, there is less of that anti-anxiety counterbalance, so it throws your nervous system off balance. It increases your sensitivity to stress and to frustration and to small mistakes that to you blow up in your mind because your brain is just dealing.
这完全是我的疏忽，因为愤怒、气愤、沮丧、狂怒是经前期综合征的一个巨大组成部分。为什么会这样呢？好吧，正如我们所知，雌激素在支持血清素方面起着关键作用，血清素是快乐荷尔蒙，也有助于稳定我们的情绪。所以雌激素下降，血清素下降，情绪波动、耐心不足、易怒随之而来。有时，由于孕酮会诱导镇静效果，当孕酮较低时，（你知道的，）那种抗焦虑的平衡力量就会减少，从而打乱你的神经系统的平衡。它会增加你对压力、挫折感以及小错误的敏感度，在你的脑海中这些小错误被无限放大，因为你的大脑此刻正在应付
with a lot right now. You may also find that your window for tolerance is a lot smaller. The little things that you would normally look past are so frustrating and so irritating. There is some evidences to actually suggest that the amygdala, which is the brain's emotional alarm system, is a lot more reactive during this time before and just as your period begins as well. So it's also about interpretation. The same things might be happening in your, your life, people may be acting exactly the same, but everything, like your interpretation of these events and these stimulus and these situations might feel increasingly threatening or upsetting. I do think the same tips from before apply, just take care of yourself, take step backs when
很多事情。你可能还会发现你的容忍窗口小得多了。那些你平时会忽略的小事变得如此令人沮丧和恼火。甚至有一些证据表明，杏仁核——也就是大脑的情感警报系统——在这段经期前夕和刚开始的阶段反应更加剧烈。所以这也是关于解读的问题。同样的事情可能正在你的生活中发生，人们的表现可能完全一样，但一切——比如你对这些事件、这些刺激和这些情况的解读——可能会让你觉得越来越具有威胁性或令人沮丧。我确实认为之前的那些建议同样适用，照顾好自己，在需要时
you need to communicate openly with whoever you feel comfortable with that this is what's going on. Just give yourself space and time to feel agitated. But then, soothe or find a way through it through exercise, through boxing, through creating art, through talking about it, through some kind of movement or processing mode. Final question. Does PMS get better with hormonal birth control? So, hormonal birth control is actually one of the frontline treatment options for PMS because most birth control contains either synthetic estrogen or synthetic progester. So when you add in more of these hormones than what your body suddenly or currently has available,
后退一步，与任何你觉得舒服的人公开沟通，说明这就是当前的情况。给自己空间和时间去感受烦躁。但随后，通过运动、通过拳击、通过创作艺术、通过倾诉、通过某种运动或情绪处理模式来抚慰它或找到渡过难关的方法。最后一个问题。荷尔蒙避孕药能改善经前期综合征吗？所以，荷尔蒙避孕药实际上是经前期综合征的一线治疗方案之一，因为大多数避孕药都含有合成雌激素或合成孕酮。所以当你引入比你的身体突然或目前能够获得的更多的这些荷尔蒙时，
it will assist with soothing some of those symptoms that have become uncomfortable. It does still have its downsides and it does still have issues as any medication does. No medication is perfect. Definitely consult your doctor. My experience, I found that it helped a little bit, but everything that I was feeling was still there. it just felt a little bit muffled. Like it felt like I was, you know, under the water in a pool and was like looking up and there were all the things that I wanted to feel.
它将有助于舒缓那些变得让人不舒服的症状。它仍然有缺点，也仍然存在问题，就像任何药物一样。没有哪种药物是完美的。一定要咨询你的医生。以我的经验，我发现它有一点帮助，但我的所有感受依然都在。只是感觉被稍微闷住了一点。就像我觉得自己，（你知道的，）在游泳池的水面下，向上看，那些我想去感受的事情都在那里。
And I wasn't really able to because for me, birth control also had some, you know, emotional blunting effects. But all in all, if that's what you're after, it could be very, very useful. Just talk to your doctor. See what they have to say. Okay, four rapid fire questions. We got them all done. I hope you learned something from those.
而我真的无法完全感受到，因为对我来说，避孕药也有一些（你知道的，）钝化情绪的效果。但总的来说，如果你追求的是这个，它可能会非常非常有用。只要跟你的医生谈谈。看看他们怎么说。好了，四个快问快答。我们全都答完了。我希望你们从这些问答中学到了一些东西。
Thank you to the brilliant listeners who contributed. I really appreciate getting to know and understand what you guys want to hear, what is pertinent to your life right now. So keep them coming. Make sure you'll follow me over there at that psychology podcast. There's going to be so much on the new book, so much on new episodes, asking you to vote, asking you to contribute. So please don't miss it.
感谢做出贡献的杰出听众们。我真的很感激能认识并理解你们想听什么，什么与你们目前的生活息息相关。所以请继续提问。确保你在那里关注我，那个心理学播客。关于新书会有很多内容，关于新单集会有很多内容，会邀请你们投票，邀请你们做出贡献。所以请千万不要错过。
I would love to see you over there. And until next time, stay safe. Be kind. Be gentle with yourself, especially if you're having. a rough time with some PMS, PMDD symptoms. We will talk very, very soon there. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway
我很乐愿在那里见到你们。直到下一次，保重。保持善良。对自己温柔一点，尤其是当你正经历经前期综合征或经前期烦躁症症状的艰难时期时。我们很快就会在那里再次交谈。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听的是《狠狠吸取教训》（Learn the Hardway）
with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability
由您喜爱的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯为您主持。这个空间专为黑人男性的经历而设，进行在其他任何地方都不太安全的坦诚对话，但您是在与一位知道自己在做什么的执照专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这个能力
that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness,
并不意味着你需要这样做。请在 iHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2%。这就是在也有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了心理坚韧度的科学，
fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist,
健身，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一边成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是在 iHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听 TWO%。当一群女性发现她们都约会过同一个惯犯骗子时，
they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends, Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
他们采取了行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他不会就这样逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友，听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。
On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here,
在 iHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从 1979 年开始，这对我和说是个重要时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利希。每一集，我们挑选一个年份，
unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild... It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过难关的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家一起。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论 80 年代一样。84 年是一个疯狂的……这是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。在 iHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。
This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一个 iHeart 播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。